Now it starts.
Welcome to the exchange of knowledge.
Tackle global challenges together. We are Elena and Martin
Lichtentaler from mytirol and we are
very pleased to be able to spend the next 90 minutes interactively
with all of you.
Many thanks to
the bellen University Alliance, a
consortium of the three major Berlin
universities  the Free University of
Berlin, the Humboldt University of
Berlin and the Technical University of
Berlin as well as the Charité of the
University Medicine Berlin for the
trust and
willingness to experiment in organizing this evening
together. We are here in
the New normal Hall and we will commemorate the
evening together with you  In order
to make the new normal a bit interactive
and so that this evening is as
relaxed as possible for all of us here,
we have asked a few people that
they will have the opportunity to speak,
but please speak to me when
we ask you to. There are
about 40 of us, there are two of us  Exactly and
they're missing the sink but I can't see that
yet, the seating is actually perfect,
we'll be moving around a bit during the 90 minute appointment,
that's why we've
built this open space back here, trust us. In
addition to the interactive exchange, there will
also be very familiar elements  For
example, there are discussions with experts from
business, science and the
foundation sector. The more they get involved
in the evening, the more they take away with them.
In this sense, let's get started,
we are curious about who is
in the room and what connects them with each other.
We will now make various
statements  meet and ask you
to come to us if these statements apply to you,
just walk across the room, that
means it's best to just stand up
and we'll go into this open space at
the back, please stand up and
leave everything behind. There have been
a lot of events now
Where you sat, it's good
to stretch your legs a little bit.
Please come to me here, I'm here.
If you think we live in a time
with particularly great global
challenges,
don't be shy. Please come to me
here if you don't  then
you don't have to come here if you
find it then I would be happy if
you raise such a small trend
if you find that we live in times with
particularly great global
challenges I would be
asked in the group maybe very
briefly just a word or  two-word
answers
are interested in which ones, what do you
think are the global
challenges or climate change
yes other voices
education system other voices
exponential growth different
at the same time okay
you are also welcome to come to me
over here wherever there is space if you
sometimes feel overwhelmed by the global challenges
yes, if it's too much for you, if I'm like that,
a little too much is a good thing and
you wish there were less going on sometimes  have to
learn to forego certain things,
perhaps privileges, wealth, etc.
a very homogeneous audience I would
ask myself very briefly, perhaps briefly, do you already live it
in everyday life and if so, how
can I be here Markus no,
unfortunately I live it  not yet okay,
honestly there are people who are doing without
at the moment
in this large group here, so
both at home, not all
rooms are heated anymore, that's a
restriction and it makes a lot of sense
at the moment more votes
Vegetarians okay thank you, please feel
free to come to me if you  We think that global
challenges can only be solved together. Let's
see. We've found
a few things where we're not
alone. There are
limits to cooperation, so
there are limits to
something together where we can't necessarily
work together anymore to
solve them  What connection now,
when there are such global challenges, there
are things somewhere that
people say, yes up to this point, but after that
we can no longer continue together.
Certainly there are limits, so
people also have different opinions about what
they want to invest
or what they would like to do in return  want to give up
other voices still
I think I think it's
always best together so there's
actually no limit okay thank
you very much 10 applause okay please come to me
if you think that the dialogue and
exchange between society and
science could work even better
[laughter  ]
well at least and then
I don't always have to
have all the guards on the collection day so they can
only bring me in on the outside
[laughter]
yes I had a quick question
so how how could this exchange of
dialogue go better is there
anyone who has this question  happy to answer
yes
no
the question was how the exchange
between the dialogue between
society and science
could go better do you have an idea
not so much journalism
more in common okay
more ideas on this
really listen how do I get it
scientifically brewed also
practical and executable  in the
target group I miss listening,
thank you
and the last question in this blog,
please come to me if you think
that Germany should concentrate more on its national interests in view of the
global challenge
yes
no, well, you can do that, that's exactly what
I would say, what would you say
to what extent, well, if you don't even
know what an interest is, it's
hard to advocate for
cooperation and I think Germany
overlooks the fact that it is actually the
leading power in  Europe is and the
fact that Germany does
n't take on this role is a problem for
Europe, thank you very much,
okay Mr. Ziegler, are you
still moving in that direction or would
you like to say something else, I can
approach you, there is always  this
rhetoric that says we can
only solve the world's problems
together and secondly, Germany
is so small in terms of the share we
have there, so we can't solve it anyway
and then you stop
moving and that's it  I think it will
ultimately be fatal, yes, thank you very much,
good thank you. Please come to me
if you are a scientist or a
scientist.
There are a few more, yes, exactly, we
might get to the finer
statements, okay,
I would be interested in a
quick question about how many how many
They don't have academics in
their circles of friends,
yes, everyone nods here, everyone is
not a graduate in their circles of friends,
okay, please come
to me if you work in the private sector
or leave me if you
don't work in the private sector,
that's one too  Possibility
how long have you been working for your
company
25 years
are also a private sector how
long have you been working for a company
and on the two devices are they very much in
line with the mission vision of your
company
now
installed in any case
please come to me  If you
work in the foundation sector, foundation
sector, foundation sector,
okay, I have the question: Can
all problems be solved with money?
No, absolutely not, but money does
n't do any harm
by promoting that is
quite important thank you excellent
please come to me if you
are a politician in a politician
or are moving away from me so that I
know who is
not a politician in the room
university politics yes university politicians
yes well I take note of that because
I'm standing now  none on request
okay then please come to me if
you have founded one or more companies
in which area of
software development and what motivated you to
found it or you to found it
exactly you
[music]
well
the desire to change something and not
just to analyze and  to no longer
be dependent on external
donors but to earn the money yourself,
thank you very
much, please come to me if you
are an activist, an activist because you
see yourself as such, you
can also have a part-time job, it does
n't have to be a full-time job,
that's definitely easy if you're comfortable with it
So identify with that
they come and otherwise I can ask them in
which area they are involved in
which area they have been involved in for a
long time in the area of ​​women's promotion and
now also climate protection, thank you very much and
they are
and in particular the laws of nature,
thank you very much.
Come to me if you are too  None of the
groups mentioned have heard of it so far,
so again, economics,
foundations, companies founded,
activist,
but I would be interested in a few voices,
which group did
you belong to, for example, a student, yes, other
students, there are other
feedbacks, yes, I work in
science communication,
science communication, other
science management  the Bua
Science Management
other voices
the same too
okay thank
you then please come to me we'll come
to the end of this part if you think
that democracy as a form of government is
currently experiencing its greatest crisis
or go away from me if you do
n't put it in that
's not the case  the case
or little last question last question
please come to me if we if you
think that we have to be much more radical
in rethinking or acting
yes in what respect maybe Gerrit
I have to think for a moment so that I do
n't get in my head and say
something  Aspect,
well, when it comes to collaboration
between science and society,
driving bolder models,
sometimes experimenting,
sometimes trying something out where
you don't know beforehand what will
come out of it, I think that's important,
very good, thanks to other radical approaches
that would like to be shared  the
paradigm shift okay yes behind me yes
I would like to say I am a big
fan that technology is relevant
and that we can achieve something with it but we
have to redefine renunciation positively
define that the two belong together is
crucial for me thank you very much
then please follow me  in the front
here behind you around the corner if you feel
addressed with the name Günther Ziegler Andrea Marriage Henning Bantin or nia lemons and if you do
n't do that you can now
sit down again or
look for another comfortable place in the room
this somewhat interactive introduction is
completely useful  simply help us to discover
a few things in common here in the room, we
are now about 40
people here, so
that you can take a few positions, you
can take a position, the
space was a bit tight now, that's why
we were always wobbling back and forth like
this  such a wave pool
but still and that you can also use a
little of the collective swarm
intelligence of them because
we have great experts and
initiators here in front of you but
of course it is also super interesting what you
all are
bringing with you this evening, we are
very happy to see you  To briefly introduce the exciting experts
and initiators
and to have won them over for this
evening, that would be exactly what
Professor Dr Güter
Ziegler is, he is the President of the Free
University and also a member of the Board
of
Directors of the Berlin University Alliance
right next to him Andrea Marriage  from the
Technical University of Berlin, she is the
head of the
science communication project laboratory and
then here we have Henning Bantin, he
is the managing partner
of IV GmbH, which is
the Institute for
Organizational Communication and
he also heads the education
and science committee of the Association of
Berlin Merchants and Industrialists
So that's a bit of the
business representation today and last but not
least Dr Nina Lemons she is introduced
to the Joachim Herzstiftung based in
Hamburg, which is primarily committed to
education, science and research
and also advises the
Federal Association of German Foundations.
Women marry global
challenges together  This is a
huge topic, so if we
pick out this exchange between science and society,
how important is it and what
is important about it? So of course it is very important, but
there are also many other aspects
of this question that are very important  What's important is
the exchange between science and
society, i.e. science and
society, that's where it starts. It
's often challenging for me in that sense
because it's still often
a very hierarchical structure, so it's
often based on science
We only see that we know something,
society or the public
may not know that and we
just have to educate them and as soon as they
understand that then they will
act but also to allow this
flow back from society into
science and to
find formats for it  And in general, I would also like
to say to cultivate a state of mind in science, that
this is possible, that it is a
big challenge for me, perhaps yes,
please ask, are there
already very specific formats that you work
or they are
very committed to  active in this area,
you can perhaps name one specifically
[laughter]
I have a lot of experience in the
area of ​​exhibitions, for example,
that you show interactive exhibits
and, if possible, in a, let's say, pleasant,
relaxed setting in which
people can relax  also
feel welcome and also
feel welcome to share your perspective
as part of society I would also
see the economy Mr. Bantin what
importance do cooperations have
in the economy today,
perhaps on the one hand in cooperation
between business and science
but also cooperation  Within the
science of economics, how do you see
that? I think it's a pretty
interesting process of change, especially in terms of
terms, because I think that many
companies are currently very
forced to learn that cooperation
is critical to success in order to be able to
be a successful market in the future
and that of course makes a
difference  Changes not only
individually but also culturally in
the organization, so I'll
just mention one of the examples now is
that the emergence of digital
platforms is necessary, so the
economy works more and more data-based on the
basis of digital processes,
machines talk
directly to each other, so to speak, and as a result
Company boundaries as we
traditionally know them are dissolving and
of course that has an impact on the way
you think about business models
and that's pretty
profound, so that's why it's about
cooperation in a pretty
violent way, but of course there are
all of them so there are still a lot of them  Not, but you
're in the middle of it. Now it sounds like there are
parallels between vehicle shift in
science and society
today, but also in business. It's
just that people
get more involved with each other and concentrate less on themselves, so to speak,
exciting perhaps here too
I would like to say that they run
along the logic of the
business model, so to speak. I mean, of
course there are partners with whom I want to
work together in a meaningful way because
they are mine  Supporting the business model
just the definition of the business model
is different than in the
past, in which I
always became more successful the more
dominant I was able to shape a market
and this one-to-one dominance
no longer works but I
need to be a successful market
often  very good networks but as
I said, we are still in the midst of
change, that is anything but over and done with,
thank you, very exciting, Mr. Ziegler, if
we stick to the topic of cooperation, how do
we create mutual respect,
mutual respect and trust in
cooperation and what is there perhaps as
well?  Spokesperson for the Berlin University
Alliance, what is the specific
approach? So I think first of all
we just have to realize that
science and society
and the economy are not blocks
that oppose each other and where you then
have to build a bridge between them,
but that they are  very, very
diverse and heterogeneous
structures and now you
just have to look at it. I think we
first have to look at where we actually
stand and that means that we are now
competing with the Berlin University Alliance with the
aim of positioning Berlin science
for this, so to speak  that we
tackle big challenges together, we first have to
look at where we stand, what we can do, what
the challenges are and then
you realize that there is a very
diverse science in Berlin
and then also the society with which
you want to talk and talk  has to and
where it is of course also important that
we have a common understanding of things then of
course it is not homogeneous, I mean
the Tagesspiegel reader is not
homogeneous and the woman on the street
is not but then you
actually have to think about what the topics are
and  That's who I want to reach with it or
who do I have to reach with it and that's
also a new thing in
science communication that we have
to reach people, so I
organized mathematics in Germany almost 15 years ago and we were
super proud of it  So we reached ten million
people to talk about mathematics,
now last year before last
we only had to talk to
science and society about
vaccinations and vaccines and it was
completely clear that it wasn't enough to have
10 million people somehow do
that with them  Discuss that I would then have
eight million of them vaccinated
and the situation has changed
and people and society and
science are not
homogeneous, that also makes it interesting,
but part of the challenge is how
these topics are found, they say
we have to know  Somehow we
also have to find the topics
in the exchange. There are
certain examples where they say that it
worked well, that vaccination is
basically something that came to all of us from outside,
so we had to
deal with what there are other
ways to do  There are other
approaches, so I mean there are
the big challenges of our
time, they are there, you first have to
recognize and
evaluate them and just see where you stand
and if I
and I mean I say we're
all talking about climate change, so to speak  The
big challenge of our time
is that
you first have to look at what it
actually is and where you
actually have to go about it and what you
actually have to understand. It gets
complicated. It's a different topic, which we also have
again from the woah, we have what
you wrote in the application  In 2018
we said
social cohesion social cohesion
is a topic that is now not quite as
obvious a topic
where you have to get to it where you also have to look at what what does it
mean who cares who does it affect who does it affect
how do we
perhaps convince people that it is them
and then it has also
become such a hot topic during the
pandemic because of course all the
newspapers have written that
social cohesion
in Germany is now completely
falling apart and if all the
newspapers write that then of course it is
also true in society's
perception but it is necessary  That's why it's
still not true and there's
a nice study by Steffen mau
Humbold University sociologist who
looked at it, just
scientific people said, now
we'd better take a closer look at that.
German society isn't falling apart that much,
but then you notice
That's such a big topic that I
think and where you have to get started
but first you have to look at what the
topic is and how you
can somehow narrow it down and make it workable
and which aspects of it are relevant.
Very exciting Ms. Lemons, what
importance do foundations have in
these global on these topics this
global challenge has just
said you find the topics like what is it like
for you from the
foundation's perspective it is very similar
that the topics come to you or you
discover them and
yes how important are
cooperations?  That
's a lot of questions for you at once, so
although I'm of course firmly
convinced that foundations can make a very
significant contribution,
you always have to leave the church in the village,
so I usually ask when I
get to know someone and they ask me
what do you do?  I say I
work for a foundation always the
question the counter question how many foundations
are there in Germany
wild guest how many foundations are there
in Germany
throw any numbers into the
room
700 others who offers more less
2000 is there anything else
24,000  about 24 hours, which are of course
very different in size and
are also set up very differently, so
big in the sense of budget and also the
number of employees and so on, that
sounds like a lot but you
have to keep saying it, so now
I'm not a different small number
the large number of people but
if you look at a lot of the foundations,
so most of the foundations work on
the four big topics of social culture,
science and education, our foundation
is active in the area of ​​science and education,
this is really a big
topic but if all the foundations
come together and put their money  If
they were to be thrown together then they would be
able to finance a school day, that
's the dimension of what the
state pays and what foundations
could pay if they want, so that means
we can do a lot, but we ca
n't replace the state, for example, and
that's very very  It's important that we are
clear about this,
they are also always bound by what
the founders have written in the statutes. We
know that.
I didn't know that either. I've only been
with a foundation for four years now. That's
really the law when the founder
writes in there  Education and
science are promoted but not culture
then you can't promote culture so
these are certain
guidelines that you have but how do you get
to the topics so our founder, for
example, wrote in education and
science with certain signs
and something very important  is that you
then just look at yourself and that's why you have to
talk a lot with others, especially
in our case with education and
science because these are usually
state tasks or state tasks
or state tasks
where there are needs where there is something that, for
example  State or
federal or state agencies
cannot do this and
foundations can then come in. These are
especially things like pilot projects or
extracurricular projects, for example
in the education sector and on the subject of
cooperation if you then throw your money
together or use your knowledge, their
precise strength and  For example,
some people are
limited to the fact that they can only work in one city
or only in one federal state
or only in two federal states.
If they then come together then
the whole thing of course has a much greater
impact and greater leverage and that is
something that I  In the not so
long time that I've been here, I've
also noticed that we're talking a lot
more about where we
can join forces and that's why
I work in the federal association. I
'm the head of the education working group in the
federal association and that's how it works  It's
also about looking closely at what
we've done successfully, what
you can perhaps simply carry on
or take over. Do you see it in a similar way to how
Bantin
described the dynamic in the
last few years to the federal association? So
as I said, I can
only do it now  Four years ago I
did something completely different and knew little
about the foundation system, but I have
the impression that this
is now an important topic, especially in order to
deal with these huge crises that we are dealing with, so if we
just look at it now  The area of ​​education in
which I am now particularly familiar with the foundation system is
where you have to work together to
achieve something and the foundations do that.
We really talk about it a lot
and if it is just
to exchange knowledge and not repeat the same
mistake again,
for example  Because it
's a very honest
discussion and we, for example, are involved in
quite a few alliance
forums and so on, and
we look for exactly those that
are right for us or where we
can contribute something and I see that
as  really makes a lot of sense and
that's where you can make progress. Yes, what
you're writing about sounds very productive,
thank you very much.
When it comes to the topic of cooperation, there's also the important topic of responsibility. When you join forces, you have to
clarify the responsibilities in a certain way, otherwise you're
in  The pleasant situation is always a
bit of a concern. That's not really my
area. It's the colleagues who are
responsible for it, etc. Mr. Ziegler. In
this context, responsibility, how and where do
scientists have to get more
involved,
so
when we talk about the responsibility of
science, then we're talking about it
again about very different things
and I think
one thing that we also discussed in Berlin
is,
so to speak, what kind of
responsibility
lies within science itself. Then the question is how
is science organized and how is
it organized in this way?  then that
also goes out productively and carefully,
like how do you organize
science so that the quality
is guaranteed, that is also under
the impression of all the
cases of forgery that you know of, but there
is also the
reproductive crisis where you notice that
What is then published is
not reproduced in the end and was
actually worthless in the end and
we at the Berlin University
Alliance then raised the question of the
quality of research, so to speak, and the
responsibility that we
have in science
Tape written that is now
actually a thing where
society could then say well that
science should just do it, that
is their responsibility, but that
also includes topics like Open
Science, i.e. simply
the responsibility that we as
science have,
not just science
but also to make it accessible
and
that also includes the
responsibility to make science understandable
and
where it affects us it is
simply important
to make it understandable to make it accessible
and my impression is that in the
end it simply no longer works  to
say at the end here we have the
findings, believe it, calculate it cleanly,
but in the end you
just need to take a look at the science so
that now I'm back to
the vaccines, you get an idea
of ​​how vaccines are actually
developed  There are tests involved,
large studies, errors
and failed attempts, so for me the
most convincing thing about the vaccines is
when you know how many vaccines have been
developed and then
failed and that the
controls are running and there is
the view, so to speak  into science,
taking part in
checking,
seeing, hearing, everything is pure and in
this respect it is not
the responsibility of science here and
society over there, but rather
this is a shared task.
You may also see a brief demand
within the science system
that the incentive systems change for
the scientist, that you do
n't just get involved in the sense
of here is the result: I have
done my part,
ideally in one and the abstract
is actually only written for a
specialist audience but how
is there  To encourage changes in
the incentive systems change,
of course they don't change
because systems do nothing at all, but
the question is where are
the incentive systems
that come from the fact that
salaries are paid to the scientists?
The
incentive systems come from the fact that they are
In the end, society just
wants to see what has been done and in
fact we have to
think about the
incentive systems in science, they also have to
be changed, but it is very
important to me that politics doesn't
come along and say that  Now the
incentive systems are not allowed to change that. That's
why we have university autonomy. That's
why we have the autonomy of
science and that's necessary because
it's necessary for the freedom of
science and ultimately from the
freedom of science and Article 5
Paragraph 3 of the Basic Law
says  also that the responsibility
is with us to organize it in such a way
that in the end you
can trust science again woman marriage you have
just nodded and smiled at me
I think there are some thoughts to be
expressed on this, perhaps especially from this
perspective  the scientist for
the next generation if they
can wish for something like how science
will be done in the future in terms of incentive systems
but also in
terms of development opportunities and scope for design, what are what what
is, their positions on
yes, I think what is a big one for me  The
point is to reflect
within science, so if we
say that science has the
freedom to decide for itself,
then perhaps
the question needs to be asked now, especially in such a time of upheaval,
what do we want as
scientists?
How much communication do we dare to do and to be
honest and
say okay, we have the task of
communication then we also take
responsibility but then we also have to
allow time for it and
allocate the resources for it was current,
it is often the case  something that
comes on top of all the papers
that you have to publish in order to
somehow stay in this system,
here in honesty and then also
making the resources available if you say you want
that,
very exciting Mr. Bantin
Responsibility  Economy maybe a
question is economic cooperation,
so you had already explained it before,
the strength, the growing
interdependence contributes to the need for more
cooperation, but are
economic cooperation always about
profit maximization
companies in a certain way or
where does the responsibility lie? I think right
now  Example of Mr. Scholz,
who has just returned from his trip to China
with VW and BASF
in his luggage and when you read that you wonder where
the 24.2 didn't exist for his colleagues or
I would like to think about it before I
get to the question  I'll take up a point from Mr. Ziegler
that I find very interesting,
namely the topic of vaccines. I
think it's worth, in the sense of
science communication or
cooperation in general, to
imagine the scenario that one would have
worked in expert councils on the topic in
parallel from the beginning of the pandemic  In addition to the entire development of
pandemic politics, including the development
of vaccines, these
expert councils would really have been
made up of all disciplinary relevant areas
and would have made this very publicly
transparent, including in dialogue with the
public, because citizens have
legitimately interesting questions about this
topic and, to put it more generally,
that is the case  Yes, it may not have been the last pandemic
that we will face, so
the keyword is a pandemic resilient
society. I think that's a very
nice example of how you
can show how we actually have to and
between all sub-sectors of
society, whether it's
science or business or whoever
We always have to
work together in the future in order to
be better prepared for such scenarios,
so I actually think that
the pandemic is a wonderful example of
how you can deal with such issues much
better. Now on the topic of
economic responsibility, I
think that might be a good example
Sound a bit provocative, but
actually it's a truism. First of all, it's
the responsibility of companies
to make money, so we
have to have a profit.
When you say it like that, you're often
looked at strangely, but I'm the
managing director of a company
here in Germany with almost 300 people
in it  700 people internationally and they are
all people who want to earn money
with families and all the
trimmings and that's why of course whether
you call it profit maximization
or not but of course of course
we also want to earn money every year,
especially in times of inflation, a
very important one  Topic and it
really gets on your nerves when it doesn't
work, that's the way it is despite all the nice
talk, maybe that's not the case, but that's the way
it is, so that's why yes, I
think it's a very,
very important topic, but not all the less,
despite
I think the challenge  of the
future, it is always important to understand what is
a really resilient
business model for the future and if
you look back a few years and
look at how the topic of
sustainability was discussed in companies for many years,
then
it was ideally under the label, if at
all  Corporate Social
Responsibility and that was ideally
a nice brochure with a few
nice projects with smiling children
yes in the education sector often
somehow in the third world and so
on in quotation marks yes
and that was a staff position posted
by the CEO and that was it
um and  That wasn't linked
to the company's profit interest. That's
exactly where the
problem lies and that's why I think it's extremely
right
and that, as a tip against this
excess profits tax, what do we do with
companies that really make ashes
with renewable energies? Yes, that's good
So yes, they should make a lot of money if
they successfully produce renewable energies,
there's nothing wrong with it
because they've taken the right step to
link their business model with what a sustainable future
has to bring with it and
colleagues who continue to rely on, I would say,
outdated business models
like BASF or VW now, so we're
not just relying on that, so yes,
exactly, but that's never that's
a very interesting point because
I mean now I would put BASF
here as a very positive example
that has made enormous changes
in the last few decades,
but of course if you
look at the German automotive industry now, they
've missed the trend for far too long. If
you look at such organizations,
these are
incredibly difficult things to change. The
German mechanical engineering industry, i.e. engines,
didn't have an engineer  In the mood for
electric, it just wasn't their
world view, it's damn difficult to
control tens of thousands of people, it takes
time
and that's why I think you
always have to be fair and see
where they are on the way, it's
not zero and one but yes a little bit
It was already late so
[laughter]
they had already done it before in the
interactive part and when asked
the question, can you solve all problems with money,
no, but it helps to
have some and they
just showed us that very clearly
Foundations have a lot of leverage
when they get together, but of course
not as much as the state does now,
but rather there is somehow a lot of
impetus, from their
perspective, are there limits to cooperation or
could we actually use a lot
more?
No, I think there are  There are no
limits, that was already
said before. There is also this big
initiative. I just have to
think about who did it in America.
I think the perpetrator had said that everyone
should somehow have a billion or
something deep enough money
a word yes and yes
you can make a relatively big difference.
I have to say no, I think that the
cooperation
and I would like to give an example of
where they have a special effect, that fits in
with what
was just discussed at the other table on the topic of
communication  Science communication
We are also a foundation that
deals with science and
the topic of science communication
has been close to my
heart for a long time because I used to
work as a journalist at some point and
long story short we managed to do it
together with four other large
foundations  and the donor association to establish an
innovation fund for
science journalism,
which has just started its second together,
we have already selected several projects in the first round,
it's about developing new
forms of journalism that
will be relevant in about ten years
because we  assume that
the form we have today will simply
no longer work in the long term or will
no longer reach the target groups that are now growing up
and that is, for
example, something that foundations can
do really well in cooperation, so I
have to say that we have one for the first time
Sausage hung in the window and
attracted the others. That's
always nice. People say we'll
do this and that. How about it
give you a jolt? It took a
bit of persuasion,
but then everyone was
on board with enthusiasm and you can see that
you can do something and you can do it. There
was a long discussion in the BMBF about
setting up a foundation for science journalism, which supposedly isn't possible. I
had another idea, but it doesn't matter,
you can green foundations, it's not that
difficult,
but then we just said
okay  We're going to take this into our own
hands and do it for
a few years and then we'll see,
maybe the BMBF will take over it
or someone else, it could also
be the Ministry of Economic Affairs,
all sorts of things can be thought of.
Ultimately, journalism isn't just for that purpose
Science or somehow a branch, so to speak,
that's what I really found, for example,
or I think that's I
love this project because it simply
shows that you can achieve more together
than alone, because alone we would
now have what it says in the newspaper 300,000
euros or now
just 400,000 euros  for the fund plus
the office
and so we have - I've now
forgotten the numbers and the 1.5
million - that makes a difference, definitely
leading bike sample and
thus bringing in some kind of dynamism somewhere,
but the idea always has to be
right  So if you don't have a good idea
then you can't
convince anyone, but I just knew that
that was true, of course I did
n't think of it all on my own, I had
already talked about it a lot and
then you can convince people if you do it
somehow enough
is enthusiastic, also convincing, great
ideas and are getting into action again,
a successful pilot project,
thank you very much. Now we have heard a lot from the
experts here. We also want to
get back into the interaction a bit
and Mr. Bantin made it sound a bit
nice at  The
issue with VW is not that
easy either, it is the
engineers to train and we
would now like to work with all of you to
address the issue that
affects us all directly or indirectly,
namely the shortage of skilled workers and that
can mean a lot, yes it can  For
example, the increased competition for
talent means that we notice
in science that we notice
in business that can mean the
changing needs of younger
employees that can
be the influence of the pandemic where people suddenly
changed their jobs in a very disruptive way  have
migrated to completely different sectors,
this can be the issue of migration,
waiting times if you just
want to renovate a house or an apartment or
even need a craftsman for
something and also that this is the
issue of whether we live in the times in which
we can actually afford it
Not all people can be active in the
labor market, so we can
do more to integrate everyone and
they all look up or they have all
found a pen and a pad of paper in their place. You are
welcome to pick it up now
and here at the front  a few
heads that everyone is taken care of
looks like this
exactly pens backwards through hand at the same time
cooperate wonderfully very
well
we would like to give each other a minute
for them to write
down their first thoughts in silence, really write them down and
not
censor them, just write down what they say  What's
going through your head from your very
personal experience from your very
personal perspective, what comes to mind
about the challenge of how can
we meet this shortage of skilled workers?
From now on
we can write down several things
and no matter what aspect,
please do it for yourself,
it will change
wonderfully  would be a minute now
we ask you
to find a partner, preferably someone you
don't know, maybe you have to get
up for a moment, move around or
manage to
do that now or just turn around
to the row behind you to do this, please
raise your hand if you  Have
n't found a partner
yet, everyone has found what they're looking for, it's best to have
someone you don't know
behind them. There's someone right behind them, so just
raise your hand, they're all
taken care of, thank you,
or as perfect as that is and then please
focus again for a moment
here  the focus forward, exactly
with your partner with your partner,
you now have the focus again very briefly,
please now have two minutes to
share the ideas you have posted on your little ones, please listen to each other actively
Then it gets a little louder and
let yourself be inspired try to put it
together a little bit,
yes, maybe there are
similarities in parallel exactly what how
can you combine the two ideas
two minutes from now
half of
children's jackets at the end study
wonderful that was two  Minutes
you find an end with your partner
with your partner please pay your
attention and then feel free to
relax once again
fantastically
conclude your thoughts
you are welcome to
stay with your partner with your partner
straight away
thank you
express your final thoughts and then
to relax again for a moment, great,
now we ask you to get
together with another couple, find
a few in your area and put them
together as a group of four and listen to me
too carefully and now please before you
do that again  Listen briefly to what
you should do.
Now please
exchange ideas and approaches to solutions in these two pairs and
discover again what are the
similarities, what are the differences
and, above all, agree
on an approach to the solution as a
group of four  consider it particularly important
and it's best to
appoint a person who
can say it once for everyone in one and two sentences
four minutes from now
[laughter]
with which we go into the
thank you super thank you very much
we both go into the audience
one two three  four five six eight nine good
ten let's do
the pendulum exercise last,
then we'll do the way back and then
we'll look at each other
in the office and then
now that's shorter
you would do 555
half a minute they're slowly coming to the end
please stay another half a minute
now  in the groups and we I
go to the left you go to the right
and that's four minutes
please stay in your teams of four
we'll come to you now and make
a quick query to find out exactly what
you're doing just stay in your
teams of four sit and give a gift
Give us and everyone else your
attention.
Please stay here again in the
fourth, I assume there was a
team of six. I think I'll just take you
first,
what is the solution approach, the idea
that you as a group of four and six
considered to be the most important thing
Well, of course we had a lot of
exciting opinions, an opinion that I wo
n't elaborate on now but that I also
think is good is no limits, yes no
limits. What we
can now present, I think, is a
suggestion on how we
can make training faster and more effective, a very concrete
example  That would be the endpahl, this is
one of the few unicorns in the
German-speaking market that puts solar modules
on the roofs and
thereby gives themselves a
competitive advantage because they have
taken the big problem of where are the skilled workers who can do it themselves and have founded an academy
have in the vicinity of Berlin where they
send out several hundred people every month who can do that, that is,
the one problem
identification, what do they actually
really have to be able to do and for that and only for that
we train them in a complementary
app that is then brought to the specialists
where they are  the
entire process is documented, is
supervised, and
we need appropriate
quality control to ensure that
the question of what
tasks were then two more points
so that I can also
transfer this to other areas. We do
n't just have these challenges
in the solar industry  also
elsewhere, for example in the
care industry, very very extreme, I
think we agreed on that, yes,
you should try clear
problems, short training for
this problem and quickly
identify the problem and then I assume
you could probably solve it and
then a legitimately important one came up  Of course,
we live in a
social order where there are not only
entrepreneurs but also
trade unions and politicians and
you would have to
take them along with you when it comes to something like this because of course the
entire basis for discussion by
trade unions in relation to tariffs and
so on is based on more complex
training paths, but that was it
The suggestion is great, thank you very much for
this input, so needs-oriented
and then also moving forward wonderfully like with a pilot project.
I'll take
this group of four and maybe very
briefly four big topics that
concerned us, firstly the
migration regimes that need to be reformed,
so it's not easy  only
exploitative structures on a
global market are, secondly,
reforming remuneration and recognition cultures,
why does a doctorate help me in the
housing market more than a master's degree
or any training? So that's
a
question for society as a whole. Behind it, of course, is
the educational system that we
deal with here in the group  where
change processes have to take place on very different levels
and finally one topic was
to what extent the unconditional
basic income could help,
but I didn't really understand
that, I'll say it again, that was also a
topic after it came up as an impulse and
I'll go  to the next group what what
was your solution approach from which you say
that what we considered to be the most important, the
wonderful the brevity the better
exactly then I will briefly summarize what we
thought but they would have to
explain their point again separately
We haven't really
caught up yet,
yes, we've essentially
seen that migration
is an important background in order to drive the
innovative power, I'll just say it now,
and that
Germany is becoming more of an
immigration country and also that there is
more time
and quality in the education in brackets
means that, so to speak, the
time factor is given greater consideration
in training and that will
certainly be reflected in the quality of the
work in all
areas. We have not
focused on the shortage of skilled workers, wonderful,
thank you very much  Thank you, I would
just continue with this
group of four, thank you, yes, we have
also focused on lateral entry,
so that's trial offers
for other professions and it's
not so rigid, so we had
a teacher with us, so it
actually starts in  Kindergarten then
also in primary school that the
educational paths are already prepared and
given and that you
actually have to start there and then
later in life there are trial offers
that you
can take up a different career and also that there are
support options if
you do  I would like to take on the job,
for
example, when people have care tasks,
you can provide further
support, making it easier to change
careers, how do I get to
you here, a group of four, divided into four,
wonderful,
so what was your main
thought?  you would like to share in the group
so we had several thoughts and
our consensus was
that the working conditions
need to be better in many areas and
the pay also
needs to be better in some areas that that
can solve a lot and with better
working conditions we have  For
example, I thought about working more flexibly
in order to be able to work better at family and work
and to be able to pay your respects, but also simply to have
more appreciation for certain
professional groups. That fits a bit with what
group two said, I think, that
a lot of young people somehow feel the
pressure to study even though they don't  It
's not for everyone and it doesn't make sense at all,
so I can live in our society
if everyone is just academics and
there just needs to be a lot more appreciation
for craftsmanship, for example, thank you very much,
I'm back here the ferry
group, thank you, yes, our approach  went in
the same direction when first
saying you actually have to look closely at
who, when, where and why there is a
lack of skilled workers, not just where and
why an approach was also to provide the image of the
professions and the pay but
what
if the pay is actually good in
some areas  In the nursing sector, for
example, when there are structures within the
hospitals or nursing facilities
that young people
are put off because, for
example, they always have to work the evening shifts and
weekends
during their training because they don't
have any children yet and then they say, well then
If I see that structures
prevail here and there is an unwillingness to
change that, that I'm not
being approached, then I'll look for
something else because I can do it, so I
think there can also be a craft business,
so a bakery doesn't have to be looked
at  Six opens or ca
n't we as customers get
used to the fact that it doesn't open until 12 o'clock
when we then have more bakers,
for example, so changing the
social aspect again
and yes also the image is the
academic title because everything is or is
again  to say that you need
all areas and that promotion only through
university is no longer possible today anyway
and that's where you look more and
motivate more, yes, the
skilled trades or ihk stories
say that you sometimes earn more
and that from a more visible perspective  doing
wonderfully, I think we have
n't heard from two groups yet, just briefly
report which group hasn't said anything
over here,
the microphone is coming behind you, just like that. We did
n't make it that specific, we
kept it a bit more general, what we definitely think about
So we all immediately thought of
creating incentives, which
means now we thought about the
shortage of nursing staff,
better pay and simply
jobs that are simply missing and
perhaps better salaries or
exactly what we
were able to agree on was further training  to promote
it is simply made easier, it is made easier to
continue training somewhere else in addition to work and the entry
and transition so I think it has also been
mentioned that it is made easier and
qualification is also somehow a
topic I think that would also be said somewhere so
what a degree  If a master
is good somewhere, it's
exactly the same.
Otherwise, a shortage of skilled workers can
also arise due to simple
planning errors, i.e. it would be
something educational policy-related. There
simply needs to be more
future-oriented action or
planning, thank you,
wonderful, we all had groups
in the plenary session, one is still missing here at
the front,
you know  the microphone over, thanks
exactly, so we actually
had all the points that have now
been mentioned, that was particularly
important, so
working conditions were
already mentioned, especially in the
nursing sector, that the working hours
are simply a little more flexible and also these 40-  Hourly week, there have
also been studies that say that the 35-
hour week might
be a little more effective, or the 30-
hour week or four-week, four-day
week work, and that would also be quite
interesting to perhaps
try out such concepts in order to attract qualified workers
to keep
exactly and then we also had
a point simply more children
because Germany
tripod solution
that maybe more
qualified people will come along and
maybe also less
social pressure so what do
I want and what does society want so
that somehow you can
do something like that  Finding a compromise exactly,
thank you very much, it's a nice transition, I think
finding compromises has
a lot
to do with cooperation and
we had a group of four here at the front.
What is the
solution approach that the four of you
considered particularly important, I think
you can  Also talk about your microphone Approach to
a solution So we have, so to speak,
used education as an answer to the shortage of skilled workers and half of the
group was actually involved in
vocational training and we were here
on the side of course with
university education but in both
people the findings on the one
hand  The people who come in
initially do
n't know what their skills are, what they
want, where they actually
want to go, they come with very
different requirements
and in the end the education system has to
be designed in such a way that it can
deal with this, which needs flexibility
Accompaniment that needs
encouragement, those were the three things that
we had there, even if you
look at a course of study, that actually part
of a good course of study is to
find the subject
to change at some point and not to say who is
changing the subject, so that provides
one  Dropping out of your studies for
statistics but rather
finding where you are actually
going or the
interdisciplinary thing so that you
have studied one thing and then finish the other
but that is a type of
design with flexibility
accompanying
movement which is also what happens  On the
one hand, skilled workers will be produced when they
arrive, what they are happy about, what they can do, where
the talents match what has been
found as a task and that is precisely in
university education in vocational
training and ultimately we also
said that we should start very early, so
that is  Yes, in kindergarten, so to speak,
educational biographies begin
with I want to when I grow up
and I can do something special and at
some point I'm there to find out what
my talents are and what I
can do with them and in that respect I
think so too  Starting very early
with flexibility, encouragement,
support. I think it's a very nice
image, the image of encouragement, because it's
like that. We used the word
shortage of skilled workers and instead of
talking about the shortage, it's actually more about
encouraging with what's there, what
you can do  actually make it out of it and
maybe we can do more with it
than we have done so far and as you
have also highlighted it also from the
plenum, I think that very often
this topic of flexibilization is
more flexible, the lateral entry the second
the third career the recognition of
Degrees and which degrees do we
need greater
flexibility in society, that
we are not all perhaps only focused on this
academic thing, that was
also mentioned several times,
that people question what do I
actually want, what do we society wants
from me,
even if I start, so to speak
Nowadays, work biographies
and ideal work biographies can look different
than they used to. My father started
at an insurance company in Munich in 1958
and worked until 1993 for
35 years in the same company in the same
department. That no longer exists today
and that is or is very  very
rarely and that's actually good
and right that they say along the way I'll get
requalified, I'll learn
something else, I'll change
direction, I'll maybe be
out for half a year in the course of the 40
years where you'll be working, that's it  But
everything is good and right and
I think that's a new insight, the
world has changed and that also means
that what education is about is what
I teach myself and what is
offered to me, we simply
have to adapt it to that  On
the one hand, we did this to
tackle a current topic together, so to speak, but also to actually practice a
little bit of
cooperation and not
just talk about it, maybe for
you on the panel, there was
something here that you can do in this process that we are
all currently going through together  have
what surprised you in the approach to
finding out what you said was
interesting so if I can please say
we have known
each other for an hour now and we had practically
all the topics exactly the same, which I found
quite surprising, that is, and there
were a lot of things here  Also before that means these
are obviously the topics so that
was now above all mega so orderly
migration or or immigration and the
migrants who are here better
integrated and so on I found that
really surprising but somehow it
confirmed for me that the topics
we are working on  Now, for example, foundation
work is the right one, that's also
the idea behind why you
really write down your ideas in the first round
because otherwise you
might adapt quickly in the conversation out of politeness
and so you can say
I also wrote it down, yes, and
then you can do something like that  Make a little comparison of
the bands, they
nodded, it was similar, yes, there is
a nice book withium of the
crowds where what
we have done here is
laid out nicely, why that
makes so much sense and I found the point
that you had made  In the first
statement about how we will learn in the future
and that it will be much more
targeted and
individualized, I think it is
very, very important to consider for the school sector,
i.e. that the classroom
is no longer the one in which teaching is primarily
taught from the front, but that
you can do that too  At home or however it is
individualized,
the classroom is actually more of
a place in which I can be creative or
with others and so on,
but in the company space it is
also the case that
this is a development that is coming to
the German industry
will be completely digitalized, you have to
remember that that means that all
employees in German industry,
including those who are already 50,
have to get new qualifications and who
does it, where do they actually go? There's
no other way than
exactly how they do it  have described if
people don't have this solution
on their machine in Screen, the
ISI instructs what the next
work step is and how it
can be optimized, then it won't be
possible at all, but we're
not there yet in many places institutionally  but that I thought that was a
nice example,
that's how you come up with new ideas or
get new perspectives, so it's
very exciting, but there's certainly
something on the page that particularly
stood out. Maybe now,
in retrospect,
we'll reflect on what we're talking about
here  It came to light that we actually talked a lot
more about what
or actually more about how
we structure education
and not what do
we actually teach and what are
we looking at because when we teach
in school
we still want to teach the I  Say,
teach classical subjects or do
we perhaps want to focus on completely
certain skills and also to
prepare people for the fact that the educational path
or learning lifelong learning
is a reality
Mr. Ziegler, yes, I just had to think
back, Mr. Bandin had that at
some point
I think it was about the Corona thing and we were talking about the
relevant disciplines and
I actually wanted a
catch because even in a matter like that it
wasn't clear at the beginning what the relevant disciplines
actually were and that's just it
The question then when it comes to
what content do we actually need
is primarily not clear. I think
that this classic structure as we
call the subjects is perhaps a
bit arbitrary but that's good
but what you need then and that's what it means
You also don't know in advance what you have to learn or what you have to learn anew,
and that means even
if we then qualify or
if we say
lifelong learning is simply part of it,
you don't know in advance and
that's a good thing  So with the
corona pandemic, that you need virologists, of
course I mean Germany, who also
showed what we can do, i.e. how we retrained 80
million people to become competent virologists
within eight
weeks and no one noticed that we did
n't actually need virologists at all
but actually epidemiologists
and that's something different, but in
this context it wasn't
just medicine or biochemistry that was needed,
but that the
sociologists were incredibly important, the
mathematicians, I
mean all of the modeling that
actually helped us through the
pandemic  We didn't know that either
and I think these are
simply educational biographies and if there
is a shortage of skilled workers at the end, of
course you have to react to where the
shortage is that you say that's
just the corner where people really need it, so it's
worth it  When people
say that, I can actually
imagine that in the direction of learning
and that is a
flexibilization of the entire system
but where you can get away from this:
I learned something during my studies and
now I'm finished and the next 40
years  If I do that then the world
has actually changed too quickly.
Here is another message directly from
the audience.
I would like to add something else
because in the discussion now
that education is important, that there is a
child in the daycare centers and in the  Schools have to be
started, I was missing
a bit of something in the discussion that
is still very hard in Germany,
namely the social background and how that is related
to it, so it always sounded like that,
because the kids already actually know
what they find interesting and so on and
the social  Origin in Germany
also very much determines
the path and I think that definitely needs to be
taken into account and there is
still a lot of commitment to
support and so on that is missing and
that should definitely
be included. Thank you very much for this addition,
we definitely do  We are now coming to the
slow but sure end of
this evening, so to speak, and before we and before
we go back to all of you,
we would like to ask you
a very short,
crisp question here on the panel, so to speak,
a small fire ring round  which you can answer with
yes no or one and or one sentence
yes woman marriage every
scientist should be a communicator
no
so maybe again yes
no was actually I would like
a path from who can and who has to to
who wants and who can
Mr  Ziegler has to
know science and they have to know science and
the scientific processes must always
be understandable for everyone,
it's not possible, I'm a
mathematician,
okay, and understandable for everyone just doesn't work
Even if you said
it's important that everyone has an insight
into what science does, this
idea that it has to be understandable
and that it's called
science communication does
n't mean teaching everyone everything in such a way
that they then understand it
is there in this sense  do
n't understand the right way now I've been
on the short question Ms. lemons for far too long,
which person with a
fundamentally different opinion did
you last consciously listen to?
Oh God,
because there was so much harmony here today,
so I admit I
was just back in America and
I admit that I
haven't turned on Fox again, I just ca
n't stand it, I have to be honest, but
I've listened to parts of Donald Trump's speeches
or something like that when I
lived in America, so
I did that
It's been a while now because
fortunately he's rather silent at the moment,
but I think that's very important.
Yes, I followed
a discussion between two
senatorial candidates and the
one manufacturer Walker in Georgia is
exactly what Günter Ziegler suggests  the hands
where you saw it it's amazing but
you have the question of course has a
different background and you are absolutely
right you should do it a lot more
and Mr. Bantin what did you recently
consciously avoid
flying
in general yes so
I don't fly many more within Germany
Thanks,
we're only slowly coming to an end. I'd like to
open it again here in the plenary session,
back to the pads and pens,
please, and maybe you can
write something down very briefly when you
look back at the 80 minutes we've spent here together
What will you remember?
Just take your first thought. What
will you remember? You are
welcome to write it down
tonight. Yes, the 80 minutes of the
last 80 minutes that we
spent together. What will you
remember?  what's
going through your head please don't
no censorship not dinosaurs
also nice
[laughter]
okay slowly come to the end
and we hope you've all
written legibly because now you can
wildly swap your cards with the others for a
moment so give your
memory  Away, yes, I would have said that,
trust your writing,
swap the card so that you no
longer have your own,
it was actually our
flexibility here exactly 2-3 times like to
swap across the board and then
we go random Lee then it's yes
anonymized briefly into the audience and
digitization
we would like to have a few places
swapped then you can
read the card that you have now
received
great and try to read it and
then we would just like to hear a few
voices what they will surely
remember
I remembered that we were
all at the back of doing without, but
no one actually
talked about how we really
get to the point of doing without and that would
actually be quite a lot to know
what we would have to do to achieve that and I
wonder whether science
has any power to act at all, okay
for many  Thanks
then I'll ask here what will you
remember? What's on the piece of paper?
Right here it says about the interactive
introduction to the diverse impulses and
also the good moderation. I'll
say thank you very much
There is a
question mark together and I ca
n't interpret it, that's fine
then I'll just go in here.
What will you remember about
the good moderation? Yes, thank you, that
wasn't completely
bad. If it's this round,
what will you remember?  remember on your
note there are a few words to the
person sitting next to me about this participatory
round at the beginning nice thank you very much
and maybe another vote here on
my note there is too little consensus too few
provocative questions okay too much consensus too
few provocative questions wonderful
good maybe if I  Here,
what will you remember? Not a
piece of paper, it's a piece of paper.
You don't have to understand math, but
you should have an understanding of math,
so
[laughter]
a final answer from you,
a very interesting moderation that
encourages you to participate
forward,
what will you remember?
Let's do the rounds here again, or would you
like Sieglar to start?
What's on your note? I
didn't manage
to condense it so clearly, it was too
diverse,
but you remember something
too  I remember a lot of
different things, the question about
giving up, which was just
repeated again, which I think is very
important, yes, and then also the way to do it,
which simply says where I think
it is, that's how it is again
individual decisions won't
move things in the right way, but that
would be the challenge that we
should have worked on, also straight out
next time women lemons that
they take with them both what is on your card
but what perhaps also in impulse that
they themselves still had on the
piece of paper  My neighbor is
learning flexibility open to
change
[music]
I think he's Bantin is about
to be warm, but I would say that
with the waiver, we've had
such a heated
discussion with friends about that that the
friendship was almost ruined
That's a question that we
really have to seriously ask ourselves and
answer.
Ms. Marriage, I will remember
the beautiful impulses that
come from all of us, so to
see exactly how we might agree on
certain points and that maybe  to
take this as an impetus to encourage each other to
tackle these things, thank you and Mr Vantin on
my neighbor's note that this
format worked surprisingly well
with lots of interesting ideas and what
I took away again was a short
sequence in the exchange
in mind  of
working less and so on.
I have a big question mark as to whether we will be able to
treat ourselves to that in the next few years.
Can we do without it? So we can,
we won't be able to afford it,
exactly so maybe then for
the farmers  The next challenges
could perhaps be built around the topic of doing without
or one of the
next sessions in this context
I have now heard that you should do without look
creative exactly
yes thank you very much for everything
we heard from you for everything
we heard from the panel  We have heard that we had
a lot of fun working with you this
evening and would like to
thank you very much, dear initiators, for your
willingness, expertise and openness
to get involved in this format and
also for your time for your
curiosity and your ideas  We have
n't finished bringing in a
big thank you also to the Belindian
University Alliance for their trust
and willingness
to make this evening interactive and creative
and we hope that you will
take an impulse from this evening with you this evening and
ideally this if  possible,
so
maybe you can do without, so exactly what
can you do without is the
question of the evening and how can you
integrate it into your everyday life? We wish
you a wonderful
Saturday evening. If you would like, you are
welcome to have the conversations that you started here  on the way out at the
reception of Zurich Miez Berlin
we are cordially
invited to let it end and
then you come home safe, thank you very much
[applause]
[music]